hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from round 8 of the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition and this
is I believe the best game played so far
it's a it it has everything and you are
going to enjoy it
it's Fabiano Caruana versus Hashanah
tournament formal world championship
challenge or against formal World Chess
Champion and let's dive straight into it
so Fabiana opens with d4 we have Knight
to f6 by by Anand c4 we have e 6 Knight
f3 and d5 we have Knight c3 the Queens
gambit declined is on the board and
Allen goes for the Argos in defense
Bishop to g4 Bishop to b4 we have a
trade in the center characters captures
and now Bishop top f4 just developing
the bishop to 4 instead of g5 we have
castles and now III and here Queen to b3
yeah so you can see that Anand is not
still making it clear what he intends to
do with the C pawn he didn't push it to
c5
so Khurana goes for Queen to be sorry
first Bishop the f5 bye-bye Anand and
now Queen to b3 as he still didn't
decide what to do with the C pawn Anand
goes in Knight to c6 which is very rare
that you will develop a night before you
actually develop the C pawn but okay
Bishop to g5 now painting the knight
here now and here comes well there is
one game where rook to e8 was played but
here Anand place
a5 and it is a new move in the position
so already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game
Anand prepared a very sneaky pawn
sacrifice so here he's asking what do
you want to do as well the d5 pawn is up
for grabs maybe but you first you have
to remove the defender of the of the of
the pawn so here Fabi plays Bishop
captures on f6 we have Queen captures an
S on f6 and now the thing is or you
cannot capture with the night since the
knight is pinned but you can capture
with the Queen but this results in an
incredibly complicated game which surely
unprepared as he went there willingly
into this rook F 38 attacks the Queen
Queen moves and now b5 with yet another
pawn sacrif
Queen captures and now Knight captures
and d4 so a temporary pee-pee sacrifice
night cat force on d4 and now even c5
and now you will win back the the piece
and the White King is still in the
center of the board if you move of
course you allow captures and c3 with
check then Queen captures with check you
lose the rook end well you're just
getting destroyed so here after Queen to
f6
Fabi says ok I will grab the pond but
first a3 first move your Bishop so I
don't have to worry about this pin so
here aren't just captures it but not
right away first he plays a5 soiree for
kicks away the Queen Queen captures on
d5 so he forces this and now he captures
on c3 Bishop captures on c3 with check B
captures and now Knight to a5 going
after the b3 squared to go after the
rook on a1 and let's not forget bobbies
King is still in the center of the board
so here if Abby says ok I grab the pawn
let's let straight Queens and on and
says no thank you sir he goes Queen back
to c6 and he attacks the c3 pawn now
with with the possibility of check and
now c4 by Fabi and what do you play
yes your your Bishop is hanging here but
if you capture Queen captures with check
rook is a grabbed and that's just game
so here c4 now asking on underwater
you're gonna do I'm still gonna capture
Bishop here and Allen goes Knight to b3
and here Fabi said okay now I could
maybe play some like croquet - but then
Bishop g4 comes and my king is still in
the center of the board and all of these
pieces are running up around my king
rugby a true t8 is coming and it will
not be pleasant
so here Bobby decides he's already up
upon when I give up the exchange he
plays Queen captures on f5 we have
Knight captures on a1 by Anand and now
Bishop to d3 developing well threatening
mate we have g6 by Anand and queen back
to f4 and now Knight back to b3 you
wanna get your knight into the game so
what do you do here we have castles
bye-bye Caruana hehehe
he doesn't want to go for something
barbaric like Queen h6 because it's very
easy to defend May twin f6 here and
Queen g7 so you don't have to worry
about that as I know a lot of you were
worth thinking about this so we have
castles by Fabi and now Queen to b6
offering a queen trade but now hobbies
down the exchange so now Fabi declines
and now he goes for Queen to h6
basically when when Anand forces him to
Queen to f6 you have to be ready for 9
g5 if it comes
and now c5 so what do you do here b6
trying to destroy this very nice pawn
chain we have C capture C captures and
now Knight to e5 and already it could be
a bit crowded here if Bishop comes to c4
also comes after the f7 pawn f4 f5 is
coming you could maybe open up the
position like this so even though Anand
is up the exchange he's still down upon
and he will have to be a little bit
careful
so rook F to c8 by Anand he wants to get
rid of Coronas remaining rook we have F
for preparing f5 and now rook the c1 and
okay rook captures we have Knight
captures now the bishop is under attack
so Bishop to c4 and this is what we
discussed that now the bishop and Knight
are eyeing the f7 pawn so rook to e7
defending it and now Knight to g4
pushing the Queen back we have Queen to
b6 now attacking the a3 point but Fabi
makes sure that it will be very pricey
to go after that point he plays Queen to
g5 now you constantly have to consider
what happens if Knight h6 Jeff Knight if
Knight f6 check and here you could go
for this pawn but it like I said it's
it's a very pricey pawn because here you
get Queen d8 check Queen back the f8 and
now Queen captures and b6 attacking the
rook rook moves and now you get Queen
back to f6 and it's just again not very
pleasant yes you do have a past a pawn
but it's not it's not like you will be
able to push it because if you push the
pawn
then you just run into the very
unpleasant the bishop captures an f7
that's the problem
Queen captures Knight h6 check and you
lose the game
so okay instead of a three you could
bring another defender to
seven pawn but then f5 comes and it's
again very very hard to defend this with
black one one point being that let's say
we track Queen g7 then Queen d8 check
and here you again wonder your queen
Queen f8 when how you go Knight h6 check
the Queen is Spencer we have to go here
and mount f6 check removes the defender
of the Queen King captures Queen
characters here with check so it's going
after this pawn would be it would be
very risky so Anand offers a queen trade
Queen e7 Queen the b5 now by Fabi now
putting pressure on those Queen side
pawns and now King the g7 and here Fabi
ignores the points on the Queen side he
continues the attack we have f5 so f6 by
Anand and now comes Queen to d5 now Fabi
threatens Quinta g8 checkmate we have
Queen to f8 defending and now F captures
and g6 with eight chapters and g6 and
now efore by Fabi so it's still on and
still have the exchange but Bob is a
very strong center and and the active
pieces are giving Anand a lot of
problems so here we have Queen to c8
putting pressure on the bishop still
controlling this Square and putting
pressure on the night although there was
the possibility for unand to play the
beautiful b5 here it forces a capture
error with the Queen or with the bishop
and basically if Bishop captures you no
longer have this bishop queen battery
eyeing the the g8 squares so now you can
capture on e3 create a passed pawn then
you return the Queen and then you start
pushing the pawn so this was this was a
possibility for Anand but instead he
went Queen to c8 and now h3 defending
the knight on g4 as the Queen was
attacking it and now rook to d7 pushing
the Queen back
Queenie sucks pinning the rook and out
Queen to d8
attacking the d4 pawn here but now you
have to be very careful if you play
something like d5 then rook the DC just
wins the Queen the Queen is not trapped
you don't have a square so Fabi of
course goes for e5 now with a lot of
threats against the f6 pawn we have f5
by Anand and now comes a
that well Fabi wasn't happy after he
played this move he said so in an
interview after the game well it's also
possible for me to ask you what you
would play here so that's exactly what
I'm gonna do feel free to pause the
video what do you play here well I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as its it's a move
that's almost impossible to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
Fabi played Queen to f6 check and he was
not happy with this however Knight to f6
is deadly point being that after rook to
e7 attacking the Queen you have Queen to
d6 now and it seems like a weird move
you're gonna ruin your pawn structure
your night will be undefended however
not all is as it seems Queen captures
pawn captures now you cannot capture
because of captures and you cannot go in
front of the pawn since the number night
covers that square point is after you go
back let's say Ruby 790 delivers check
King f8 and mountain knight the c7 locks
the rook out of the game and also the
night and pawn create a wall against the
black King this is just some very very
impressive chess rook b8 hoping to bring
the rook back into the game but now 96
check King e8 Bishop b5 check the only
move King f7 now just defend d5 and now
well there are a lot of ways to play
this but we're just gonna give one line
for example might be three bringing the
right into the game d7 now King to e7
now comes King f2 Knights the c5 finally
and now finally you bring the pawn all
the way because you wait basically until
the night lands here and now you win
back your exchange characters captures
captures and now comes King III and it's
the exact same material however fabi's
King is a lot more active and he does
have the the past the D pawn so white is
definitely to be preferred much problem
probably it is winning with with the
absolute best play but Bobbie didn't to
go for Knight of 6 he went for Queen f6
check and now comes Queen captures on f6
with check sorry without to check he
captures with check King h7 and now
Knight to e5 attacking the rook rook
captures and e4 is well somewhat
problematic because of f7 and now how do
you prevent the queening you could go
back but then you get Knight to d7 and
here well it's basically a draw
you cannot capture because of Queen but
you can play King g7 and now white wins
back his material captures captures
captures and now yes black is up upon
but Bishop b5 picks it up and it's equal
material so if if Allen goes for the
point it's basically a draw but Anand
wants to go for the win now he goes look
to b6 now attach the f6 pawn f7 and now
King g7 and now you don't have any
sneaky sneaky tricks to go something
like 97 because well the king is in g7
the rook would just gobble it up so
Knight back to f3 defending the d4 pawn
and now Knight to b3 Anand starts
bringing the knight back into the game
Knights the g5 now and here comes Knight
to d2 attacking the bishop Bishop to e6
and now comes Luke to d8 just a great
defender and here okay
if the bishop wasn't here you would have
check and and this but there's always
time for that first it's time to bring
the King into the game King f2 and now
best for Anand is Knight to b3 add
another attacker to the to the pawn here
and also just start bringing your knight
back into the game however I don't play
the King to f6 and if you don't know
that there is a hidden hidden secret
here a king of six is a perfectly good
move however here Fabi has a really a
very nice move so once again feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
move that Fabi played in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it it's actually not a faith queen if
you found a faith queen yes that's
possible but then after captures check
you're gonna capture on e6 captures on
f8 with check King if 7 goes after the
knight Knight to d7 and now Knight to c4
defends this pawn and the tags this pawn
and after let's say King you to start
bringing the King in there again b5
comes white knight no longer has a
target you are eliminating the a three
point and you will have two connected
passed pawns on the Queen side so this
would in fact be losing if you decided
to go for this
well aesthetically pleasing check but
it's not the way to go and for those of
you who found Bishop to d7 however
congratulations and this is in fact what
Bobby played for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show and now of course
you cannot capture you cannot capture
the night if you capture the night you
get Bishop the e8 and the next move it's
just a queen on the board and after
Bishop to d7 if of course if you capture
the bishop then again you bring the
Queen inter game so here Anand played
the only good move for Black Knight e4
check we have Knight captures pawn
captures and now Bishop the I ate and
here kink the e7 so keeping an eye on
this square but now kink the e3 now
hobbies King starts getting more
activity we have rook to b8 preparing to
push the pawn but now fob you can just
eliminate the pawn bishop character
Sunday for and here for some reason on
and it doesn't capture the f7 pawn which
is just weird
here Anand first played b5 push the
Bishop back but now if Abby just played
Bishop to b3 and he defends the pawn
which is which is odd and okay rook to
e8 Anand goes after the a three point
King captures on e4 we have group
capture 783 and now Bishop to e6 again
preventing capture because of queening
and here b4 is the only move that that
has well activity left four four four
black since the group will help the pond
across the the be three square the
bishop will not be able to capture it
also rook to a6 is possible just going
after the dishes but here on unplayed
rook to e1 and now he gave Bobby a very
very important temple d5 so okay rook to
d1 preventing b6 but now if Abby just
plays Quinta King to a five and here a
valiant try was rook to e1 check
bringing the King back and only then
playing rook to f1 but here Anand plays
rook to f1 without forcing fabi's King
to move back and now Fabi just advances
the point d6 check King f8 and now King
to d5 we have worked the f6
but now d7 King to the e7 and this is
where the magic happens here Fabi plays
King to c6 and yes this is possible it's
incredible
I mean even if a rook captures on e6
we'll check you have King c7 and there's
no way to guard against a queen if you
play rugby 6 then you just queen the
other point f8 Queen King captures and
now you capture here and next move you
bring a queen into the game so king c6
what what a magical move so here Anand
tried a key route back to f2 but here
King captures on b5 we have rook to be 2
with check King to c6 and now rook to b8
keeping control of the back rank but now
kink the c7 and it was in this position
unmoved 61 that Vishwanath honored
resigned the game as there is no way to
do anything here to quickly demonstrate
if you move the rook just the bishop to
d5 you're gonna transfer your bishop the
rook is under attack for example rook to
b8 you can never leave the background if
you if you leave the back rank you just
first Queen this pawn than Queen this
pawn doesn't really matter or or just
this point since its defended so rook
the d8 but now you go King c6 and after
some move again you can never capture
here because if you capture here just f8
Queen captures and captures and it's of
course again winning so here black would
just have to wait g5 but now g4 rook the
a8 and now h4 pawn captures g5 you never
have to worry about this one since the
bishop coverage the h1 square so it's
not a problem
you're just gonna have to wait through
vd8 g6 group to a 8
g7 and now any any move wins for white
so really a beautiful game by both of
them and again showing that chess is
definitely ruthless on and played a
brilliant game he he outplayed Fabi in
the opening he out prepared him he was
pressuring him pushing with all his
might but chess is just ruthless and
Indian it's Fabi who takes a full point
sir
that's the game I do hope you enjoy that
like I said after King c7 the game ended
and here are the standings after round 8
so we we can check that out I don't know
if I will be showing any more games from
round 8 so here they are here we have it
Fabiana Khurana catches up to ali reza
fallujah with five and a half out of
eight followed by five points west I saw
Jordan run Forrest then with four and a
half yung shue stuff Duda and Magnus
Carlsen all of them both of them still
going going Abbott they are not doing
the Giri anymore though they each have
one win then with four points Daniel
Dube of onigiri and vladislav RTF with
three and a half of SH wanna turn on and
with three Jeffrey's young and with two
and a half
Nikita fatigue of young Yi and yes
Vladislav co-ed have won one game today
against Jeffrey's young so now his he
also caught up to young he and Nikita
with you of so really really crazy stuff
tomorrow
anything can happen it's interesting to
point that ali reza tomorrow has white
against Magnus so that's gonna be really
intense but also I don't know which one
is that but Fabi will have white against
Alvarez or so far be has excellent
chances on winning this tournament it's
gonna be it's gonna be really crazy so I
do hope you enjoyed it once again I
would like to thank Robert Fischer and
Nicole Agri for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata Steel the women's
watches championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent receiver Sunday or if it's
already Monday - you know sorry about
that